all right nathan tylenbaum here at the
eight news now traffic center freeways
in town are okay but a heads up you
cannot get into arizona people in
arizona cannot get into the boulder city
area now you can certainly use u.s 95
but i-11 is that most folks use an hour
and a half ago a vehicle fully engulfed
on the i-11
just west of the hoover dam so these are
the folks who are backed up there we
have photographer chad graves on the
scene and here he is looking at the
scene it looks like it was some kind of
an rv that caught fire but fire crews
are still on scene and the freeway
remains completely closed let's go back
to the traffic computer we'll continue
to keep you posted as i-11 remains
completely closed in both directions
between boulder city and the hoover dam
no word on injuries no word on how this
vehicle uh caught fire or even what it
is it sure looks like it might have been
an rv or a fifth wheel we're going to
try to get a conversation with chad here
in our next half hour in the meantime
the freeways in town are ok and sherry
it's a good thing that wind you were
talking about was not there this morning